i like the respect
that islam promotes i've always talked
about how the religion that identify
with the most is islam islam is always
called the religion of peace but the
messages i'm getting
it does not seem peaceful like that's my
honest reaction the amount of people
sending hate and wishing death and
violence and saying i'm going to choke
you like they're very descriptive like
there's going to be muslims standing
outside with baseball bats that you're
very descriptive about the ways you're
going to be violent how can you still be
a religion of peace you think i can
still
convert
or is it too late after the stuff i've
done don't you know that when you accept
islam
allah forgives all your sins
so if you right now were to accept islam
on the spot or tomorrow or the day after
next week or next month or next year
allah will forgive you for everything
that you've done
but i want to be very clear and say that
we can't play games we can't plan to get
to 80 and then accept islam after a life
of sin while knowing it was the truth
because that's just being arrogant
playing games with god
and i would say anyone who does that
will very likely be punished on the day
of judgment
okay chat
we are addressing everything today we
have the three muslims um
i've seen their channel before
they've said some positive things some
negative things but i understand because
i i like their channel to be honest
uh can you guys introduce yourselves
yeah for sure we are the three muslims
um i'm rami
you guys can introduce yourselves
inshaallah is
my name
and yeah we have the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims uh we also
have the three muslims.com
we just have real conversations
unscripted unfiltered just candid and uh
that's exactly what the video reacting
to sneak go was and uh i think he can
appreciate that inshallah
so
i first want to play the clip
one more time i dressed a lot yesterday
but i'm getting i'm getting a lot of
threats i'm being honest yo
religion of peace the stuff i'm getting
is is very very very violent and you you
know how you know how it gets a lot of
well like i'm gonna slit your throat i'm
gonna come and find you i'm gonna come
to
attack you they're even like racial
slurs but i get it it's a lot of people
it's the internet's the nature of the
internet but i do think that the clips
were taken out of context
but i will learn i want to learn why
that was disrespectful i want to show
people why that was disrespectful
because i did not know
uh
yeah
i think an important fact on both
behalfs right on both halves in terms of
the people sending you threats and you
yourself is that in islam we separate
the sin from the person
so we can accept that obviously what you
did
is this is the sin that we dislike
uh
and not the person and that's what it is
as well as in islam
you want to obviously say it's you're
getting some crazy messages for the
religion of peace however obviously
we separate
the person from the sin it's that same
thing so it's good on both behalf that
type of thing you know i mean
and you guys have seen the clip i'm
going to play i could share the screen
but it's really short i'm just going to
play real quick for them
so they understand
okay i played the clip
now i can stop playing it i won't do
that again
basically it was taken out of context
that clip i don't know if you've seen
the original stream but i was actually
reacting to
acts of haram i was act i was reacting
towards people who are walking around
with their dicks out people at pride
parades western women acting like hoes
and so in response i was doing uh
mocking the muslim prayer sound
can you explain to me why this is
respectful
all right so
first and foremost when it comes to
mocking anything you're always going to
have people that are angry that that
thing is being mocked especially when
you have something like religion because
religion is not just something that
people adhere to or like it's something
that they identify
themselves with so when you have a go in
that and i know that probably wasn't
your intention right as you just
clarified but when you have a go at
something that is so dear to them and
make it kind of into a joke especially
when it's out of context right you're
going to have that kind of heightened
reaction so in islam
we have various verses in the quran that
talk about mockery and that the people
you know in the past they would actually
mockingly say you know tell god to bring
this punishment that you're talking
about the prophets would come warn them
about punishment and they'd be like okay
bring the punishment then allah would
god would punish them he would destroy
them and that's literally the end of
them you know ad and the mood and these
people that are mentioned in the quran
there's no side of them anymore there's
no remnants of them anymore and other
people whether it's hypocritical muslims
or angry hateful disbelievers they'll
come and they will mock us in our
religion and the quran says on the day
of judgement they will be mocked the
last thing i want to mention is there's
a narration from the prophet muhammad
peace and blessing be upon him my
brother actually reached out to me first
and he wanted me to mention this hadith
and it's very beautiful and i think it
will summarize how muslims
you know act towards a religion
the prophet peace be upon him he said
that no one will truly have faith no one
will truly believe until they love me
until we love the prophet more than
ourselves
our parents and our children
so when we have you know any mockery of
what the prophet and allah brought to us
we're going to get more angry than if
you were to mock me like if you were to
sit here and call me stupid and ugly i
wouldn't care but as soon as you mention
something about our beloved prophet
peace and blessing be upon him this is
someone who we would literally die for
if we lived at his time the companions
took arrows for him gladly rocks to the
face they got beat up they were stabbed
they were murdered and they did it
happily because they love the prophet
and they love the religion they love
allah
more than they love themselves and their
families
what was your reaction when you saw that
montage
bro i'm so happy you asked cause this is
i wanted to talk about this bro i was so
mad
honestly emotionally i looked at it and
we don't we didn't know each other we
didn't talk before the stream no but
when i saw that emotionally i'm like
honestly i was like hell with this guy
he screwed this guy you know he's being
not just ignorant but arrogant and you
know making fun of our religion who does
he think he is that was my emotional
reaction later on when i calmed down the
logical side of me is like you know
maybe he just doesn't know you know
it's just everyone's a product of the
surroundings and you know you you're you
joke a lot generally i think so
i make up fun of every religion and
before you continue i don't mean to
interrupt you but the other day i had um
this guy nick fuentes on who
speaks about jews a lot and i did the
i was making fun of the jewish uh prayer
song too i make fun of every race every
religion i don't discriminate when it
comes to jokes but i understand but yeah
just continue
100 and that's when the more logical
side came out and i'm like he probably
doesn't mean for it to be disrespectful
and i know that you on your stream
yesterday mentioned that you understand
why it's respectful that you won't do it
again and for me that's enough i'm not
gonna sit here and be like oh no you
need to say you're sorry you need to say
the words
if that's what you mean and you adhere
to that bro we're chill we're cool as
far as i'm concerned um but i was very
pissed when i saw especially dancing to
the quran bro my heart literally was
enraged
what's can you explain to me why that's
wrong because i thought that it's music
and i wasn't trying to make fun of it
i was trying to poke fun at myself and
like my ignorance to the religion
because i talk a lot about wanting to
convert to islam islam has always been
like i talk about this all the time
that's why i have moose from the top
right uh i've always talked about how
the religion that i identify with the
most is islam i have
dave chappelle is like i have his
autograph right here he's islamic i have
malcolm x and my banner i don't know if
you claim him he's part of the nation of
islam i know that there's some
differences but i'm trying to make fun
of myself and my ignorance and not
fully understanding it but just uh just
correctly malcolm x was part of the
nation of islam but then he left and
became a proper muslim
and that's when they that's when they
got him
yeah
what was your reaction uh fan
my reaction bro was
you were mentioning something about how
you were mocking you know people that i
woke the pride parades feminists i
understand that how that related to
mocking the muslim prayer there was just
a disconnect there you know maybe i
don't understand the link but
i mean yeah i would have the same
reaction if anyone has mocked it in one
hand i'm in rage like rami but i also
understand the
state of ignorance that people are in
you know what i mean
i don't think you intended to to mean
disrespect
so at the end of the day
a lot of muslims will have hate and will
come at you sideways and i'm sure you
experienced that bro you dm me about
that but trust me when it all comes down
to
reality
if
someone repents someone turns back to
allah bro who are we to
you know put barriers in between them
and allah where no one
you know
angel can you answer this for me
uh islam is always called the religion
of peace but the messages i'm getting
it does not seem peaceful like that's my
honest reaction the amount of people
sending hate and wishing death and
violence and saying i'm gonna choke you
like they're very descriptive like
there's gonna be muslims standing
outside with baseball bats that you're
very descriptive about the ways you're
going to be violent how can you still be
a religion of peace it doesn't make it
permissible just because people are
doing it yeah i mean it's still it's
still sinful
yeah
it's um
at the end they go like
islam is known to be perfect
but muslims are known to be imperfect
so not as humans but we're emotional
we act off emotions we have egos
and um
yeah well most muslims are very very
uh
i guess you could say they have that
almost like protective
quality so when someone is
talking about about the religion or
they're they're mocking you or they're
doing something like that
they are
very quick to stand their ground
and say what they got to say which
you know a lot of times it could be seen
as a bad thing but in reality like
look at all the other religions
like they they don't stand for anything
so in essence it's a bad thing but it's
also a good thing
yeah there's i was i was when he first
made that joke i remember calling in the
stream after and i was telling him
there's different moral tolerance
between different people and different
groups and all these things so i would
tell him like look
with someone they can someone might be
able to joke about someone else's mum
but to me if you joke about my mom i'm
gonna spark you in the jaw and that's
just how it is that's just my moral
tolerance you can't joke about my mom
and it's that simple you know what i
mean so some people might say oh it's
calm i'll just talk about his mama as
well but with me that doesn't that
doesn't i'm not gonna outside if i don't
know you and you're gonna make your mum
joke my
moral tolerance is that i'm just gonna
i'm not gonna let that slide and in
islam there's a different moral
tolerance in that community so the moral
tolerance is uh we're not gonna let
these jokes slide now the moral
tolerance in the christian community
might be different moral tolerance in
the jewish community might be different
but the moral tolerance in islam is is
different to the rest of them in the
sense that we're just not going to let
stuff slide
yeah but
you want to go
i was just going to quickly say that i
want to add to what musa said his point
and in islam
if you sin it's bad obviously but if you
publicize your sins it's another thing
too and it ties into what he was saying
because the more you publicize your sins
the more you're open to it the more you
basically create an image of not taking
the commandments of allah of god
seriously
yeah and i think it's important that we
draw a line between the anger that
people feel which is good which is right
which is justified islamically we should
love what allah loves and hate or not
love what allah hates or does not love
right that's a concept it's called
but
the
what should be separated is the action
itself just because i'm angry you know
on behalf of my religion and muslims and
the prophet peace be upon him and allah
doesn't mean that i can go and you know
cut people up and threaten people's
lives and when did the prophet peace be
upon him just threaten people's lives
the only time the only time the muslims
got violent
is in a state of war when there's one
nation fighting another nation and even
then they had rules of war they wouldn't
you know they wouldn't even disfigure
the face of the dead
they wouldn't harm any innocents anyone
who's not combatant and all these things
so who are you as a muslim think about
it you're supposed to be an ambassador
of islam you're supposed to and this is
actually the main reason i wanted to do
this because i know there are going to
be people who make islam look bad
muslims who make islam look bad by being
violent and threatening and all these
things that islam actually does not
allow
in islam we're actually supposed to obey
the law of the land that we live in by
virtue of living in that land out of
respect we obey that law so imagine you
a muslim just
preaching about how you're going to go
against allah and murder someone or cut
someone threaten someone's life this is
not something that the prophet peace be
upon him would do rather a lot of the
time he responded to ignorance and
intolerance
just with the simple facts he would tell
people what's up he would remind people
what's going to happen if they don't
stop doing what they're doing and when
islam became a state there were certain
punishments for things but we don't have
a state so we do what the prophet peace
be upon him did and that's just have
these conversations you see the brother
is very
uh accepting of you know the fact that
we find it disrespectful and he's
respectful
and saying that he's not going to do it
again
what more do you want from a gun
don't you think that
we should talk about how they took the
clips out of context do you think in
that situation the context is important
i think context internet social the
that's just social media and for you bro
yeah i think context is always important
and no matter what you're talking about
whether it's something i say or
something that's written in like
scripture um so it's always important
but then taking out a context like they
said it's just the internet i think
there are people probably muslims as
well that just genuinely don't like you
and a lot of the things you preach so
they're going to do as much as they can
to make it i have a very large muslim
audience i think that's why
i'm losing subscribers i'm getting a lot
of messages from these people i don't
know what but i have a lot of message
that relates to a lot of islamic people
what do you think that connection is
i honestly don't know
i'll be honest bro
i think you
do not like the left
and as muslims we don't agree fully with
the left either
but it doesn't mean we're now far right
we don't fully agree with the right as
well we have our own beliefs
you know
i think there's also a line with
masculinity and islam because islam is
very very clear on a man and what a man
should be and we look at the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him as our role
model he had everything you know he was
courageous he was brave he was also kind
when he needed to be firm and harsh when
he needed to be and these are all
beautiful traits that a man should have
so i think
certain things that you preach there's a
certain
i'd say
demographic of young muslim men that
love hearing about masculinity and these
are the same young muslim men that go
and listen to entertain
i
really
i don't want to say despise but really
strongly dislike a lot of the things
that andrew tate says really and yeah a
lot of the things like
it's it's more so to do with
the way he portrays islam and i know
it's a subtopic so maybe we can get back
to it later but the way islam is
portrayed
with um you know having four wives
or you know how we treat our women
and maybe these are things he said in
the past but when muslim men hear this
for some reason it gives them this you
know is that this honor and they go
running for it but um
we can talk about it later but i don't
think it's encapsulated in the right
manner i think some of the things you
say as well it falls in that category as
well but i think that's the connection
to answer your question
so people like me and tate talk too much
about wanting to have four wives and
it's it's falsely representing islam
i can tell you have an opinion about
that can you say what you're thinking
i mean i think everyone
kind of thinks like that in the
beginning you know me myself being a
reaver um i kind of came from that
ideology of
wanting to be with multiple women you
know spinning plates and all that stuff
way before i was muslim
and uh then when i got into it you
converted yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm not a
muslim by birth bro i'm excited i was
catholic i was catholic by birth bro and
i became atheists i became atheists for
a long time
um but anyways you know back to the
point it's
when i got to islam i was like oh damn
like you know four wise honest so that's
all i could think about but
when you really start to understand like
everything behind it
it's it's not really how it's being
portrayed bro
like you you have the ability to have
four wives yes
but
it god says very clearly like if you
can't be just and you can't provide and
give everything to all of them equally
and just have one if you can't even do
that to one then don't even have one at
all
so get money and then you could have
four wives
it's more than money bro way more than
money bro what else
bro
being a man being able to provide for a
woman emotionally everything it takes to
be a good husband so yeah being able to
provide most of that is money i think
everything comes hand-in-hand with that
and it's also
it could be seen as like
self-improvement but it's really not
self-improvement it's more so like
um muslims know this because when you're
when you're practicing
it's more like they call it your own
theme
you know and you're on when you're on
dean you're constantly i'm trying to get
closer to the creator you're constantly
trying to better yourself constantly
trying to
purify your intentions and just be a
better person overall
you know and at that point like that's
the biggest thing that you can do
for a woman you know when you have a
wife or let's say if a man decides to
have multiple wives like this man has to
be putting in work just think about how
much time and energy it takes
to run a business
right or let's say run multiple
businesses if you're an entrepreneur or
something like that
now let's say you got a wife in the mix
but you you i know you understand how
much time and energy a woman takes now
imagine a second one a third one a
fourth one like somewhere along the line
that's another business right there
that's like two businesses
yes bro and then imagine
imagine you have three kids now can you
have kids with every single wife
yes
but now imagine that like imagine you
have three kids with each wife and you
have multiple business and you have
these relationships and you have to
focus on yourself as well and you have
to keep bettering yourself and it's just
there's so much to juggle that it's like
again allah god says very clearly like
if you can't do this
then just be with one and if you can't
even do it with one then just be be by
yourself
what did you think about charlie hebdo i
don't know if you remember for context
for the chat charlie abdul was a french
magazine a satirical car uh cartoon
magazine and they were depicted they
were very intentionally disrespecting
muhammad and disrespecting islam and
trying to provoke a reaction and they
ended up all getting shot up what did
you think about that do you think that
was just
i mean if you
this is saying bro like
if you go looking for something you end
up finding it right so yes yeah
not i don't think it was justified i
don't think it was just fight but at the
same time
you play stupid game you and stupid
prizes bro you know what i mean like
that's what it is
i obviously can't it's not justified i
don't ever think chewing up an entire
building full of people is
there's not a lot that can justify that
but
you know i mean you played a stupid game
is it very clearly like there's a very
clear reason as to why we don't draw the
faces of prophets you know i mean
you knew it he knew that still went
against it was it was an inappropriate
comment uh comic as well
yeah there are people that are willing
to do that type of thing you know
do you think that was just charlie what
happened to charlie abdo
speaking like islamically strictly the
quran and the sunnah the the way of the
prophets upon him no it was not
justified at all especially because we
don't live in you know a land under
islamic law right because if you where
was he was he in france yeah it was in
france you can't just go murdering
people willingly in france it's against
the law of the land you live in so
islamically it's not justified so you
have to follow the law of the land in
islam
yes yes you do and if it goes against
your religion actually there's a very
beautiful verse because i feel like i
know what you're going to ask there's a
beautiful verse for allah says basically
on the day of judgment allah will ask
the people that didn't leave their you
know
lands with all this what we call fitness
tests and trials and things that didn't
allow them to practice religion allah
says was my earth not spacious enough
for you to migrate
so if you live in a place where they
don't let you practice your religion you
have to go somewhere else go somewhere
else
faye do you have any what do you think
do you think what happened to charlie
hebdo was justified
nope
but there's always going to be more
charlie hebdos bro
and how should muslims react to that
type of disrespect
with emotional intelligence
understanding that these people are
ill-informed let's be honest we grew up
in the west i grew up in canada around
me grew up in canada on how's american
what we knew about islam growing up with
or without being born into the religion
is what we see in the media in the news
so yeah can you have contempt for these
comic artists and all that yeah but
you gotta understand where they're
coming from they're brainwashed too
their program too
and at the end of the day
we represent islam khabib said this
quote he said that non-muslims don't
read the quran they don't read the
hadith
they don't do any of this but they go
based on you they go based on what you
do as a muslim we're ambassadors right
so at the end of the day
was it justified no
okay and also i've i don't know a lot
about the quran but i have heard people
say that the quran says that you're
supposed to be critical thinkers and all
the people sending me threats clearly
aren't thinking critically because they
just saw the clip and got outraged
do you think that they are not following
the quran
by getting outraged at a single clip and
attacking me instead of attacking the
greater message am i really the right
person to go after
i don't think there is a right person to
go after i think there's only a right
message to convey
and
conveying that message and the way you
do it is very important if you look at
for example
moses who by the way in arabic is musa
nam so i think that's very beautiful but
peace be upon him
allah tells him to go to the most vile
person on the face of pharaoh right he
was vile he was killing baby boys he was
a disgusting person
he enslaved thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people allah says go to him
and speak kindly
and to the very end he was he never
out you know lost his temper and went
crazy and did all these things and
another story i want to give quickly is
there's a narration with the best friend
of the prophet abu bakr they were
sitting together and a bunch of islam
haters came and they started cussing out
abu bakr again the best friend of the
prophet both of them stayed silent they
didn't say anything and the same people
they turned to the prophet and started
cussing him out and that's when abu bakr
lost his mind and started yelling at
them and cussing them out as well and
that's when the prophet muhammad just
walked away peace be upon him and when
abu bakr you know later returned to the
prophet he said that you know when you
were sitting there and you were holding
your tongue and you weren't losing your
mind basically the angels came and they
gathered around us but when you lost
your mind they all left
and he said i don't i don't go to places
where there aren't any angels so that's
why i left as well so that's how muslims
should be
if it comes to a point where they need
to hold their tongue and be quiet and
not say anything not lose their mind
because they're too angry they should do
that but when it comes to a point where
you need to firmly
and honorably speak the truth and say
that we as muslims will not tolerate
this
then you have to take the action as well
what is that action is that action
violent violence
no no that's a it's not it's the only
time a muslim will be violent in the
west as far as i know is if they're
getting attacked okay that's the only
time violence is okay it's permissible
in this case it's this discussion right
here you reach out you talk to them you
make a video response you speak with
honor
and at the end of the day that's all you
can do and people will see the truth
people will see this guy's losing his
mind making drawings and being petty
this guy is being honorable he's holding
his frame and he's just speaking calmly
kindly and firmly about his beliefs and
at the end of the day people will decide
based off that
okay is jihad is that
an uh is that a
a significant part of the quran
yeah jihad is actually all it means is
struggle people think it means holy war
or something crazy it's not
the definition of google says i want to
quickly read it for the people in the
chat says jihad is sometimes referred to
as a six pill of islam throughout
history sacred scripture has been used
and abused interpreted and
misinterpreted to justify resistance and
liberation struggles extreme extremism
and terrorism holy and unholy wars
a lot of people in the chat right now i
think a lot of the christians and people
who don't fully agree with islam are
bringing up jihad and saying that it's
hypocritical that islam
preaches that it's a religion of peace
but also has ideas of jihad
what do you think about that
i mean i
with
that kind of narrative i see where the
west will come from but again it's just
a narrative that lacks context so to
explain it more jihad linguistically
just means a struggle you know we have a
prayer at like four or five in the
morning so waking up for that is a
struggle that's considered jihad you
know holding your tongue when you know
your family members yelling at you
that's also
that's also jihad that's also a struggle
wars fighting to defend your property
your land you know what your rights
whatever it might be that's also jihad
but what people do is they hold on to
that definition that example of jihad
and they make the only one there is and
i want to prove to these people that
islam actually is a religion of peace
with one or two verse from the quran
it's in chapter eight i can find the
verse later but it says a verse about
killing the non-believers and then it
says but if they incline towards peace
then also incline towards peace wait so
there's a chapter in the in the quran
about killing non-believers
there's one verse in chapter eight it
says it tells well to give you context
this is to the prophet and the muslims
at the time in a very specific situation
where they were in a state of war
already
and since they were not violent up until
this point god gave them permission to
go and fight in the war so he said go
kill the disbelievers but
if they inclined they don't he doesn't
say if they surrender he says if they
incline towards peace then also inclined
towards peace showing that muslims want
to be in a state of peace but if you're
coming against us if you're attacking us
we will defend ourselves
okay on hell and fired uh someone
donated uh jp said ask about quran 9 29
fight against christians and jews until
they pay the tribute readily being
brought low
what does that mean
as it is
it means what
so the jizya
is a tax that non-muslims who live under
islamic rule have to pay when the
muslims came into power the jews and the
christians they didn't want to pay their
attacks basically so allah commanded the
muslims to fight against them until they
just pay this jizya and by the way as
muslims we pay two and a half percent of
our savings not income tax but our
savings towards charity
the
non-believers non-muslims they actually
pay less than that and they were feisty
over even paying that towards the muslim
in the state that they're living under
so that's all it's saying basically
enforce your laws and in return for them
paying jizya
we protect them since they live under
some law and muslim power we defend them
we protect the women their children and
all that it's not that they just paid
that to like some high state power
yeah they don't have to fight our wars
for us
who do you think did 911
[Laughter]
i agree too and i'm having a debate
about it tomorrow and which is really a
little bit annoying that i'm getting so
many uh islamic people sending me
threats and everything it's like i've
been on your side about so many things i
don't i think that the american
government was lying about it in
minecraft
i'm trying to to talk about a lot of the
stuff that you guys
all of you agree that it was an inside
job it wasn't actually al qaeda in
minecraft here controlled demolition in
minecraft
yeah minecraft in minecraft oh you agree
even fan you agree with that too
only in minecraft yet
what kind of um
what kind of um
oppression did you face post-9 11 i'm
not sure how old all of you are but you
probably noticed a shift in the attitude
towards muslim people during
the the terrorist
attacks and everything did you get
looked at differently did it happen in
canada too
yeah 100 what what type of attitude did
you face from non-muslims
man just bullying in school bro
i've only ever experienced it i was born
in 02 so the year after so i've only
ever experienced i haven't seen whatever
happened before
i was i remember kids were like putting
like taking their t-shirts off and
playing around their heads just like
screaming oh i bet around going around
all the schools just like screaming it
pretending and then stuff like that they
were coming up with some silly arguments
like my granddad died to a muslim no no
no no no
and then stuff like that
but you know i mean i i guess
you're gonna hear that [ __ ] so i guess
i'm kind of thankful i heard it from
earlier when i was younger so that kind
of character built me a little bit to
prepare i want to know like angel's
perception though of muslims in 9 11 and
all that because you grew up here as an
american
non-muslim i mean bro like when it first
happened i remember i was in elementary
school bro
and i remember looking about the tv
there was like some buildings like that
had been crashed i heard what happened
so i couldn't really make nothing of it
as a little kid but as i grow then i
kind of like understood like man this
there's no way that this this could have
been this like i i get it you know the
muslims islam is being portrayed like
terrorism but
it just doesn't make sense like two and
two it doesn't link together
how do you think islam is falsely
represented in the west
you said how or why how do you think
it's falsely represented
how old i think in every way
can you name a couple what are the most
prominent ways
religion of violence religion that
oppresses women
religion that
i don't know
hates gay people and calls for us to
kill gay people yeah that quote that uh
ramy read out earlier where he where it
followed up with if they incentivize
towards peace
follow on your end as well the quote
before that i've never seen plastered so
for so much in my life where it's like
the head the non-believers wherever you
see them and stuff like that that's the
that that comes before it but obviously
the line after is if they offer peace
follow through on your end as well that
quote before that though i've never seen
so many like in brit in england we have
a there's a group called britain first
which are like there's they're supposed
allegedly a christian group they don't
behave as christians but they're
allegedly a christian group and they go
around just
being islamophobic essentially they
throw around that quote so much
that's a complete misrepresentation
and the verse itself is relating to a
specific event in history in time a
specific battle it's not even like a
general like hikmah or wisdom for
mankind from the quran
how tolerant are you of the lgbtq
community
pretty intolerant bro
so you said that uh it's falsely
it's misrepresented in the west because
you don't hate gay people but you're
also
completely intolerable of their actions
see when i said we don't hate them we're
not out here trying to crucify them
every single day we don't wake up with
and choose violence or anything like
that
but agree with the lgbt community
in the sense that they think this is how
you should live morally we disagree with
that
now my personal opinion
as a med student and all the research
that i've done
it's not that they were necessarily all
born this way or that it's a choice
i think that yeah a lot of them
are born with proclivities for example a
man born with feminine gender traits
right
and vice versa a woman born with male
gender traits
so growing up they're gonna identify as
the other type so just saying it's a
choice
doesn't really do it justice but it's an
internal choice
it's it's an internal jihad it's a
battle
it doesn't like
if you're born that way cool if you're
if you're a feminine man cool if you're
a masculine girl cool but to do surgery
and and make all this money and whatever
the lgbt is trying to promote
all this i don't agree with that
i i personally don't think it's uh i
don't think it's a choice this is
whether you're gonna be gay or trans or
whatever but i do think that it's
manipulation like obviously you're a
product of your environment if it's
pushed on you you're manipulated into
believing those things and no one
chooses to be manipulated you know what
i mean so when people say to um oh so
you think that being gay is a choice no
i don't think it's a choice i just think
you've been manipulated that simple you
don't choose to be manipulated that's
why i used to yeah i used to think about
that too and i agree the environment
plays a good factor but there's a huge
biological factor too and what i mean by
this is allah still makes a man a man
and a woman a woman
but the stuff that they put in our
waters the stuff that they put in our
foods the stuff that messes up a kid
growing up in a woman right
it messes up the androgens or the
hormones inside a growing fetus
and that itself is what's gonna change
up the kids gender and there's a lot of
research to lock this up
what would you do if your son was gay
remy i want to hear what you think first
firstly may allah protect me from that
and all of us
we'll say
allah will protect you from but say your
son turns 12 and says
dad i'm gay
yeah well the worst thing to do would be
to kind of lash out kick him out and
disown him and all these crazy things
um
i would just kind of
honestly it's tough to think about but i
think what i would generally do at the
time is sit down and talk to him about
it okay what does this mean to you why
do you think this
and just explore it not explore it you
know in any sexual manner but like
explore in the sense that
i think that he's going down the wrong
path that he was manipulated like musa
said and uh do things that will make him
more masculine you know go host
horseback riding go uh you know arching
or if that's what it is so try to
convert him convert him back to reality
i don't i don't like using that term
because conversion therapy has a very
bad connotation because like electro
shock therapy and all that stuff but
essentially for lack of a better term uh
yeah
okay and all of you said you think that
uh islam is falsely represented in the
west uh because you're not oppressive
towards women you could all agree with
that um people are in the chat saying
that there's a passage in the quran that
says you could strike your wife if there
is a fear that she may disobey quran 434
you can hit your wife if you fear that
she's gonna disobey how is that not
promoting violence against women
yeah so again this all boils down to
context so the full verse what it says
i'm going to paraphrase a little bit but
it gives you three steps it says
basically if your wife is for lack of a
better term disobeying you're not
listening or you know doing things that
as a man you don't want her to do
uh what's the first step advise her
kindly that's the first step advise her
nicely sit her down talk to her she
keeps persisting in it she doesn't
listen leave the bed you know go sleep
on the couch or something and if she
keeps doing what she's doing it says
does mean hit but it doesn't mean to
actually like beat her up if you look at
the hadith like a soft head
i mean it's more some scholars say it's
more of a symbolic thing because a
symbolic slap
we have something called talaq talaq is
like kind of a sign of divorce so what
they would do is they would kind of like
lightly tap the arm of the woman like
this to show that he's getting pushed
towards that divorce towards that state
and my evidence for this is not just
what you know certain scholars have uh
kind of explained with the quran like
early scholars ibn kether and um
um what's his name um i've been
but the prophet himself if you look at
aisha
the prophet saws she said the prophet
never beat a woman or even an animal
and even the prophet said he said that
you shouldn't do it with anything more
than a miss walk which is like a little
stick so just just a soft hit you can
only hit your wife softly
yeah i guess you could feel like that
but it's mainly a symbolic thing how is
that not violence
well i mean if i go and i do this to you
am i being violent yeah
it's like a it's like a it's supposed to
be like a signal more more than anything
demonstration bro let's say me and moose
are squaring up right and musa says
something he's trying to go too far
it's like i'll just push him back a bit
not inciting violence not trying to
square up just like yo
just that's as far as you're gonna go
okay but you see how you use the analogy
you and musa two men
you can apply that logic to you and your
wife
bro i'll explain this clearly all right
if you're trying to get someone's
attention they're facing the other way
you type them on the shoulder if you're
not going to save you're not verbalizing
on your shoulders
it's a little tap right and and it's
signifying like look if if i'm tapping
you like this
just imagine like how i actually feel
imagine what's actually going on inside
of me like what i what i want to do now
i mean of course that's violent thinking
about it is violent but bro again like
we're human bro we're human we're
imperfect so even someone who's outside
of islam like you push them to the limit
like
they're probably gonna want to do
something to their girl
and i'm not inciting that i'm not like
justifying me but i'm saying like as men
we tend to have higher testosterone
levels and because we have high
testosterone levels if we don't keep
that in check we can become very abusive
very quickly
and this is why allah just put it in a
very simple way where it's like okay
well now you know you have this signal
here and it's just laying the middle
like look like this is where i'm at
and it's signaling like look if it
continues like we should just divorce
because it's not going to end up good
now again a lot of people take this out
of out of context that's that's the big
problem well what's the right context
well look at the prophecy before saying
did he beat women did he beat his wives
did he is there anything documented did
he ever hurt animals no
he hear animals
no beat animals oh okay
i gotta read the quran
also you're saying that um it's a
misrepresentation that women are
oppressed what do you think about the
fact that in saudi arabia women only
have been able to drive until like very
recently and they have to cover their
whole bodies women clearly don't have
the same amount of rights
it's it's clear in islam that women
do you think that women are inferior to
men
not at all
i'm pretty sure it's saudi as well
that's not real sharia all right
driving i don't think that's that's not
even a
islamic rule i think that's just
something they wanted to do in their
country that's sharia law no there's no
there's no country today there's no real
muslim country today
we just call them muslim countries
because they're muslim majority
countries and there's no country
implementing sharia properly yeah
which country follows sharia law the
best
i would say none because listen
it's literally all or nothing there's a
verse in the quran that says
that there's no one who can make
legislation except for allah so as soon
as you introduce any kind of you know
man-made i you know i want to implement
this one that you've already failed no
matter how many of god's laws you're
trying to implement as soon as you've
done that you fall into what we call
kufr disbelief because you're now taking
the role of god and making rules up
yourself and i would say there's
obviously none that are even really
close
there's i think the po the closest you
could probably get is like some obscure
tribe and like
some and then they can really do their
own thing because even in like the way
every country can implement any type of
economy
just having stuff like
mortgages which have interest attached
to them or like even school systems and
stuff like that
um they have like
in a school system obviously you have to
pay
you have to pay interest on your student
loans and stuff like that and interest
is haram so you won't
i mean so you can't do you can't
participate in any type of economy
so if i convert to islam i'd have to pay
my student loans
no very like
is is
the concept of interest is haram in
islam so in order for there to be true
sharia law implemented there can't be
any interest so
that kind of
disregards
every country because every country has
an economy that implements interest
what do you think about the fact that
musa is my editor and he has let me post
clips um disrespecting the quran should
is musa as responsible as me
should he
is he a bad muslim because of uh he
works with me
that's a that's an interesting question
uh at the end of the day it's up to
allah right he's the one who can judge
what do you think what do you think
well i mean i think that i have no right
to say to be completely honest i don't
have i don't know enough about musa his
relationship to you his life situation i
talk to him more than anybody else like
morning and night like it's the last
person to talk to the first person i
talk to it's like always business
as from my perspective and i'm not a
scholar so i can't definitively but as
far as i know
if he's advising you
then i think that's enough because at
the end of the day it's your channel and
you're he's i guess i don't know how you
the dynamic is but he's kind of like
your employee so you're going to post
these things if you want to regardless
of what he says or does i think as long
as he advises you that's all that needs
to be done he did he did immediately
like even right after the stream was
like that's disrespectful you can't do
that he called me out first
may allah bless you foreign
bibi what that means baby right
you just leave home
in islam
damn lisa personally i wouldn't get a bb
downstream like that
i'm 19 bro i'm 19.
what do you think about uh um factions
of islam like the two people that i
respect the most that are islamic like
before i started streaming and
everything like so my role models are
malcolm x and dave chappelle dave
chappelle is not a proper practicing
muslim person he eats pork and he drinks
frequently and he talks that he
is he's not a good practicing muslim and
malcolm x one of my idols growing up
uh was part of the nation of islam
before he converted um what do you think
about that can they still
go to heaven
well the prophet peace be upon him
mentioned very clearly that 72 out of
the 73 sects are people of the fire bro
what is up
huh can you explain that i'm a little
confused
so basically in islam we we don't we're
not supposed to have sect
s-e-c-t-s
or sanctions in islam we're supposed to
have just one
real version of islam following the
prophet peace be upon him and all the
other prophets peace be upon all of them
that have been sent by god as messengers
and prophets to guide mankind
but people are gonna take rulings
beliefs
and these ideologies are baseless a lot
of the times
so you got a lot of people that are for
example ahmadi right it's a specific
sect within islam
and we don't claim them as muslims we
don't believe they are muslims because
their belief system
is not in line with what we believe to
be islam so they're going to hell
that's not up to me bro
because i'm not the one that decides who
goes to hell who goes to heaven what do
you think are they going to hell or
heaven
no you don't understand it's not it's
not alcohol
what it is is the relationship between
that person individually and god so we
are no one to make that call as long as
they're repenting even we don't know
you know what i mean like it's not even
like
who are we to we don't know the sins
they have we don't know the good deeds
they have and overall it's a it's a
weight you know i mean we don't know we
don't know what they do we we don't know
any of that stuff so
there's no one there's no one for us to
make that call yeah like at the end of
the day a muslim could go to hell
and someone who is a non-muslim might be
tried fairly based on what they got and
allah writes in the quran that we won't
punish a person unless we send the
messenger so at the end of the day you
got to put two and two together and
realize
if they're ahmadi or whatever another
sect of islam that isn't true to the
teachings they have innovations they do
things that are not islamic
it's on a case-by-case basis you can't
just be like oh everything's so black
and white just because they're not part
of sunni islam they're not going to go
to heaven you know what i mean are you
all sunni are you are anyone she in here
no what's on me oh sunni is is she the
bad one i uh actually let me not ask
that question because i'm under here
right now but a lot of people are
telling me that that's the the more
militant as a small there's a small
portion of them they it's all down to
interpretation so the quran's one story
that's it because we have stuff like
quran half is all through time and stuff
like that but
um
but yeah in terms of
uh she are they're like as they're the
smaller portion majority of people that
believe in islam so you think that the
bad ones you distinguish the two uh
sunni and shia
can i distinguish the show i i don't
know the difference
can you talk about like how shiism
started
yeah so i mean the sunni shia divide i
mean back in the time of the prophecy
found there was no such thing as sunni
and what ended up happening was there
was a political dispute that changed and
eventually became theological dispute
theological differences so in islam we
have what's called a khalifa which is
like the
amir al-mu'min the leader of the
believers the leader of the muslims you
can look at it maybe like a king but
it's it's it's more than that all right
differs
and there are very specific
responsibilities that this this emir has
that this leader has
and there is a dispute over who should
be the khalifa at a certain point in
time
some people were saying that it should
have been the cousin of the prophet son
you know ali
others were saying it should have been
basically who it was abu bakr then this
companion than that companion so it's
just a political dispute and then
eventually it became a theological one
and i can go deeper but i think that's a
fair enough answer for now
okay
they're asking um did your contact fall
out of your eye
contact who
did your contact lens fall out of your
eye me oh yeah yeah i thought you were i
thought you were saying some something
in arabic no i did my contact just fell
out
um yeah it just fell out god damn
i think all those cursing me right now
you have to think positively of god bro
yeah i am
okay you're right you're right right i'm
trying i'm trying um
someone asked if the jews and muslims
follow the old testament then what's the
difference between the two
well i mean
actually allah says in the quran
generally he says woe to those who
change the scripture with their own hand
and say that this is from god we don't
believe that the torah is intact
actually we know that it's not even
i can't name one so this is generally
you know you can look it up even jewish
uh historians and scholars and
theologians say that the old testament
has been changed theologically
not just one word or change but like
theological changes have been made and
over the thousands of years there's no
way to say that it's actually been kept
intact properly um and that's not even
talking about the new testament that's
just strictly the torah of the old
testament so even if if it was intact
maybe we wouldn't have to have islam and
all that but i don't want to go down
that line because you know there's only
one reality that exists the old
testament the torah was changed and
because of that they don't have a proper
clear understanding of what god wants
from us so he sent the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him and the quran to bring
us back to the straight line and
actually all over the quran allah says
that this is just a reminder this is
just a reminder it's the same message
moses was sent with jesus was sentiment
noah was sent with um
you know lot was sent with to obey god
worship him submit to him
and basically enjoying good for inforbid
evil that's it and that's the same thing
that islam is preaching actually sneko i
think you said in one stream
that um i think i was watching this
morning a clip of it that
judaism christianity and islam are kind
of the same thing just with minor
differences yeah and i actually
appreciated that i appreciate that oh
really because that's
true that's essentially true and islam
itself will not go against that because
all islam says about judaism and
christianity and maybe even some of the
other religions that exist is that these
were
you know
initially scriptures and prophets that
were sent by god but over time the
message got changed it got corrupted
there were people who had their own
agendas that implemented their own
beliefs and wants and desires into the
religion and when it got to that point
where it was corrupted god would send
another prophet the reason islam is the
true religion especially according to
muslims is because it's the only
religion where the quran is intact and
we can demonstrate that we have the
narration of the prophet muhammad peace
upon himself and we can show the chain
of narration going back to him
and we have muslims who understand the
sciences of islam as you know the
companions of the prophet understood it
the early scholars understood it who are
practicing islam for what allah revealed
it to be not for what we or the liberals
or the conservatives want it to be
what's the beef with the jews
there's no real beef with jews to be
completely honest i mean the palestine
israel conflict in minecraft i mean
we're all free palestine right
yes ralphie palestine
there seems to be a little bit of
underlying beef from what i've i've
talked to people of all religions and
there's always like a little bit of
tension
what do you think about the jews
honestly
and answer that question as if we're not
on a stream right now
you guys want to go first
they need guidance
that's it
any guidance just like every other kafir
essentially right
yeah i'm wait musa where are you from
bro ethnically from turkish turkish
i'm the only palestinian here so i'll
i'll be the first to uh speak on it
in the chat free palestine in the chat i
mean i mean
i actually tried very hard in the last
few years especially when i was younger
and a lot more hot-headed to
differentiate between zionism and
judaism and jews right there's nothing
wrong with jews even judaism is actually
very close to islam and you know i can
respect
those some of the beliefs and the
practices for that because they actually
some of them try to be very true to what
they believe the book says and true to
god so
and they think god is so holy that they
can't actually say his name or write his
name out which you know i can respect
that as well the problem is a political
one not a religious one and i think the
more we make it a religious one the more
we fail to tackle the real issue which
is the
basically an uprooted palestine and the
political
um
i don't want to say the t word on here
but it's what they call muslims a lot
that is the israeli state
they are you know terrorizing muslims
non-muslims even you know arab
christians that lived there they don't
even let the same way they don't let
muslims celebrate eid at al-aqsa the
masjid the mosque we have there they
don't let the christians celebrate
christmas they don't let them put the
tree up i think they like burnt it down
and cut it down last christmas or
something and this is the political
issue because they don't like the
palestinian people not islam as a whole
a lot of people are asking again well at
the top i want to hear what you think
about think about the jews
angel
is there any beef
man i couldn't even give you an answer
on that to be honest
you think it's a stupid question
no i don't think it's a stupid question
i just
like personally i just i haven't really
looked into it
just being honest
okay so so rami's like the the voice of
the quran of the three of you
nah nah man i don't know when we're in
it we're in it you know i think it's
like we all have different dynamics yeah
and just like for this question in
specific i just
there's a lot of things i just don't
have the time and it's not that i don't
care about it it's just i haven't been
able to like dip my toes in no
okay and so if you if we want to stream
right now and i ask you the same
question like what you think about the
jews you would say the same thing you'd
be like i don't have an answer yeah
exactly though
exactly for the people who who don't
know about your channel can you explain
the message of your channel it's called
the three muslims so obviously your
whole view on reacting to content is
coming from a place um is coming from
islam what's your point what's your
message with your videos
i don't wanna
speak for myself the main message the
voice
i try
maybe the main message i try for train
islam is that islam is the only way to
live islam is the solution to all
problems and i think that was kind of
the route that i took with the reaction
that we did to you and the hamsa beef
and all that you know i didn't want it
there and and like you know act holy or
better than anyone stuck with allah you
know may allah protect us from this kind
of arrogance i just wanted to say that i
was in a very similar state once and
that's because we're all a product of
our surroundings we all grew up in the
west with liberal and capitalistic ideas
and that islam is the truth it's the way
to live life and it will actually make
you not just a better person but more
content in your life it'll actually make
you happier it'll make you more content
it'll make you more
i would say not tolerant in the way that
you let people walk all over you but
tolerant in dealing with people so you
can have better outcomes and social
interactions and that stuff i've noticed
a lot of these things for myself so i
want people to see that not only not
only was islam the pinnacle for like for
example the judicial system we have in
the west innocent to proven guilty even
the jury system these things were taken
from islam you know the the money that
the the baby the newborn baby gets when
you know they're giving birth to from
the government the money they're given
from the government that was started
from omar which was the companion of the
prophet peace be upon him
all of these things
you know they come from islam and i want
people to see that and recognize that so
they can recognize that islam is the
truth and accept it
they got me
battery dying no it's not battery dying
it's just [ __ ] cord
all that stuff
well okay while they're while they're
getting me with the baseball bats can
you explain what's your overall take on
my videos and my message do you think
i can still
convert
or is it too late after the the stuff
i've done
oh yeah on hell bro you want to tell
that story man no i think i would love
to
but you know the actual stories like the
hadith way more than i do so please go
take it away
so
khalid ibn waleed
is a person who even today some of his
military strategies they're still
implementing
because he was such a profound
military strategist that he was the only
person who actually caused the muslims
real harm
during war there is one battle called
the battle of
which
was a very tough day for the muslims
people were saying that the prophet died
which he didn't peace upon but that was
the rumors going around the muslims many
muslims even very close to the prophet
like his uncle hamza radhila
he was killed in during that during that
battle lanza
yeah
so
it was a very tough day for the muslims
and it was all because of two things one
some muslims didn't listen to the
prophet and do what they were supposed
to and two khalid ibn walid he led an
army around the mountain and flanked the
muslims and put them basically pincered
them
so that was very tough now this is a man
who killed many muslims and led to the
deaths of many muslims because of these
wars and the prophet peace be upon him
he actually
he knew that khalid was a brilliant man
so he asked he inquired about him he's
like you know where is khalid this man
is too smart to not accept islam like he
can see clearly this is the truth and
then later khalid came to him and he
said
you know i killed many muslims i'm going
to paraphrase a little beast like i
killed many muslims no
how can i be forgiven can you please ask
god to forgive me
and the prophet peace be upon him he
said khalid don't you know that when you
accept islam allah forgives all your
sins
so if you right now were to accept islam
on the spot or tomorrow or the day after
next week or next month or next year
allah will forgive you for everything
that you've done
but i want to be very clear and say that
we can't play games we can't plan to get
to 80 and then accept islam after a life
of sin while knowing it was the truth
because that's just being arrogant
playing games with god
and i would say anyone who does that
will very likely be punished on the day
of judgement for trying to you know make
a fool out of god
you guys are speaking like i i can hear
the peace in your voice and you you
follow the quran properly and everything
but a lot of people in the chat are are
bringing up
natural criticisms of islam and they're
saying someone asked like why one out of
four muslim americans think suicide
bombings are sometimes are often
justified if it's so peaceful like i'm
gonna ask the same question again
why any again people asking about honor
killings and everything
do do
why is that so commonly supported if
it's a religion
oh so so the thing is with scientific
studies and and surveying you got to
look at what the groupings were what the
cohorts were if you go to a place where
there's 50 people and all of them are
for some reason ill-informed they're
misguided they're not practicing islam
properly and they believe in honor
killings and all that you ask all of
them right let's say 40 out of 50 of
them say yeah i believe the honor
killings are okay and then if you go
saying statistically this means 80
percent of muslims support honor
killings
that's not science bro that's not
interesting 25 percent
it's saying 25 percent one in four
americans
well muslim americans think that suicide
you got to put the study you got to show
me what the cohorts were you got to show
me who the subjects were you got to show
me what they believe in because in islam
we don't believe in honor killings
whatsoever
you also have to think about who you're
interviewing as well you're interviewing
like americans which have naturally been
brainwashed to believe that obviously
through stuff like 911
that we are people that do suicide
bombings that's that's just
how
they perceive it you know what i mean if
you go to a country where maybe islam is
a bit raw where they have like a don
playing in the streets and stuff like
that like when it's time to pray you go
to them type of like
um villages and stuff like that i'm sure
the outcome will be significantly
different
yeah and i do want to jump in and kind
of give a different perspective you know
when you look at the muslims and the
muslim suffrage in the world like the
uyghurs in china you know the
palestinians the palestinian muslims in
palestine and in the middle east you
know iraq iran these places that were
absolutely destroyed they were beautiful
cities once upon a time but absolutely
decimated by the west
these are hurt people even if they're
american they're still a muslim they
still love their people their home
country their their home town people
they're gonna be emotional and this is
most likely an emotional response not a
religious or logical one when you look
at you know islam and you read the text
you find there is no place for honor
killing there's no place for bombings so
why do you think it's so common compared
to other religions
it's that's the thing it's not it's not
that common
look at them the look at the last like
10 mass shootings or bombings but that
wasn't done in the name of religion
though that was done for
men's like you know they went crazy
there's more more often than not i don't
want to bring up
say something incorrectly but it seems
like more often than not the honor
killings and suicide bombings happen in
the name of islam more than other
religions
it's just highlighting bro that's all it
is like the media is highlighting this
is like if if you were to go back in
time when you had the kkk
like this was a small group of people
and
now when you see christians you don't
say ah this is the kkk there's a kkk
here no no because it's not highlighted
anymore but right now we live in a time
where in islam like
oh it's just being highlighted as a
terrorist type thing but it's not that
way if you actually look into it
it's like those it's like what they what
they choose to
highlight out of their overall identity
i remember when there was some like
some guy jumped in a van and like ran
over people in london right they
identified the fact he was muslim even
though it wasn't an act done in the name
of islam or he never like it was never
anything that indicated he was islam it
was just something that they further
figured out for his identity it's the
same thing with a you know i mean if a
terrorist goes and kills a bunch of
people and then they realize he's muslim
they'll highlight it in the headline but
if
if a white kid goes and shoots up a
school and they later identify as
christian they'll put mental health in
the headline so it's just identifying
different parts of it you know i mean so
but then also
in my experience like i've made fun of
every religion every race the only
um
group of people that have acted so
angrily and emotionally and
it was encouraging violence were muslim
people i've never had so many uh threats
before and
i've made fun of every single muslim
voucher for that i make fun of everybody
why is it that islamic people are the
only ones that have really been singular
uh that i can single out and say like
yes they they
want to commit violence against me
because of a joke
but different moral tolerance bro
intolerances so there's no correlation
there's no correlation it's all uh
misconceptions
even have you changed the question you
said why are islamic people it's it's
muslims bro there's that islam and
muslim are different things bro
the difference is one is imperfect is
flawed is the creation that's us muslims
and one is
allah god
who's perfect
and his created divine revelation and
laws on mankind which is flawless
basically basically islam is the
religion in the way it was revealed to
be practiced you know god says pray five
times a day we pray five times a day
muslim is just someone who calls himself
a muslim someone who says they practice
islam is every muslim praying five times
a day no no does that mean most of them
are
i think a lot of the people sending me
threats are probably not perfect
practicing muslims is that a fair
assumption
do all of you pray five times a day
musa i know doesn't
um don't call me
no no i'm just being honest we're being
honest on this stream uh i'm my average
is like three four
that's when things are i'm getting there
but three or four times a day
yeah well i was traveling today so i
only have to do three i think but
the combined praise
yeah
musamela bless you bro and and sneak or
as muslims bro our etiquette is to put a
blanket over the sins of our brothers
because we believe that on the day of
judgment allah will put a blanket on our
sins bro
but tld to answer your previous thing
your recent video is talking about how
you know the system wants to make a
sheep and control us and programming us
and and they don't want us to find the
truth and they'll silence us and they'll
delete our instagrams and all this type
of stuff right
if there was a system i'm not even
talking about islam for now but if there
was a system that would free us right
that would free us from the powers above
that would not allow this wealth
disparity where people are suffering and
those elites at the top have all the
money no interest right
would they want to present that to us in
a good way or would they want to vilify
that on on the media so people are
scared to even look into it
can you comment on the hadith they're
saying that um
hadith means that the muslims who change
their faith should be killed i don't
mean to just ask you about about
violence and everything but these are
these are the questions that are arising
and i have to admit i'm a little bit
curious after seeing the reaction um to
that viral tick tock
yeah
there there is a hadith or the prophet
peace upon him he said something along
the lines of if someone if someone
abandons his religion and betrays his
community than to kill him there is a
concept of hadood which is capital
punishment for apostasy but it's more
than just you know not being muslim
anymore it's kind of being you know
non-muslim in the charlie hebdo way
where you're going and you're inciting
this kind of like hatred or
for example if someone comes and they
say that something that is pinnacle
that's a pinnacle of islam like five
daily prayers someone comes and they say
this is no longer obligatory you don't
have to pray anymore what will happen
islamically and this is outlined in the
quran they would be sat down in a
peaceful quiet place for three days and
they would be told if you keep doing
this then you will be killed if you keep
doing it you'll be killed for three days
straight and if they keep persisting in
it then they will be but this isn't even
necessarily the case because in the time
of the prophet peace be upon him this is
called the treaty of hodeidah
he made a treaty a pact with non-muslim
land
where if anyone basically apostates in
the way that i described which is
basically like a breaking of social
contract revoking uh revoking the
citizenship if you want to call it that
if that happens they will be safely
transported to the non-muslim land to
live there
so
it's like a worst case scenario thing if
someone but it is a scenario
worst case scenario yes
but it's a scenario encouraged in the
quran
i believe so is it
do you guys know i think it's i think it
is outlined in the quran
and just backed up
i'm sorry bro i'm like i'm kind of
passing out so
i can't even comment on that right now
what's up with you are you tired
i made friends i'm in france right now
bro so it's like
almost
it's it's 1 1 30 1 30 am bro and i got
that leg man what you doing in france
charlie have doses some [ __ ]
no i'm not playing play
don't make jokes i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry again apologies but you you just
messed up the entire stream bro they
coming back after you bro
write them out again [ __ ] it
i mentioned i went down in this car i
was gonna suggest
i got it i got a question for you yeah
you mentioned this a lot on some streams
about islam and then if there was one
religion that you identify the most with
would be islam yeah i hear this in a lot
of stuff that andrew tate says and a lot
of people in the manosphere it's always
just talking good about islam if i had
to bet on one religion it would be a
song
but then they don't really do anything
about it so my genuine question to you
is where are you because of your views
on islam and your own personal journey
with god
i like the respect
that islam promotes and i think in the
west i agree with tate i agree that like
you the the comparison is that you can
walk around uh with the shirt that says
jesus is gay
and nobody will blink an eye like i've
heard i've had one-on-one calls with
people and they said like yeah i'm going
to a party that's it's twerking for
jesus and i'm like what that's
and jesus like people
being anti-christian is marketed as
it's fun
it's something it's like the rappers are
all like having a crop dropping crosses
and the in the in their album covers on
screen they they use satan to promote
their music it's
anti-christian in the west is a fun
thing that people use it's an aesthetic
choice but i like the fact that islam
doesn't tolerate any of that and i i
think that most islamic people have
their heads screwed on properly where
they have a sense of guidance that they
can follow
that keeps their morality in check
whereas a lot of other religions and
other
um
other
um
thought
like trains of thought
it can it could derail you and i think a
lot of people now use their political
ideology as their religion they use lgbt
as their religion they use like
democratic party and it's just like
that's not or they they adamantly
believe in
people and they worship celebrities and
politicians rather than god and i think
the best if you're gonna follow
something it should be god
and in the west it hasn't been
christianity and i personally grew up
catholic um just like angel and
catholicism i i've just seen a lot of
hypocrisy in it where like i we have
something in catholicism which is called
confession where you sit down and then
you you you confess to the priest and
you use and then no matter what you did
even if you killed somebody like you can
literally confess a murder and be let
talk about [ __ ] out of wedlock any
sin and the priest will say all right
say 10 hail mary's 10 our fathers and
you're good and i sat in confession it
doesn't really sound like they're
listening i don't like it the fact that
they walk around with the donation
basket um i'm pretty sure it's it's the
same with with the mosque but
like the christian church doesn't pay
taxes a lot of people profit off of it
there's a lot of pastors like even on
youtube some of the most highest um
super chatted channels on youtube are
christian pastors and i've just seen the
way that they flock to and it just seems
false and
it seems like they worship a lot of
false idols and people use christianity
for the wrong things but islam seems the
most grounded and it seems like it
promotes family values and conservative
values and
more than more than most people that
i've spoken with and especially the
people that i admire the most um since i
was a kid have all
found is even people that did not grow
up with islam found islam people that i
admire like dave chappelle malcolm x and
i respect those people a lot and i i
would like i like their trains of
thought and i think that that's a good
thing to follow
it's not just the foreign wives thing
it's not just the four wives
that sounds good too
do you do you believe in one god
the truth is i want to more than i do
i think with my platform now and the way
things are going on in the west i think
it's important for me to promote
believing in god and i think it's a good
train of thought for people to follow us
but there's a lot of people that listen
to me and i think that believing in god
is the best
is the best train of thought to follow
but i to be perfectly honest i want to
believe in it more than i actually do
what's what's stopping you
because i think that
i personally think that god is something
that
is internal like before
i've always
followed the idea that god is love and
that we we know
right from wrong internally if you do
enough self-reflection if you have
enough self-awareness you know right
from wrong and you can follow that but
religion is important and god is
important for the mass population
because a lot of people without it don't
have a proper sense of guidance and
that's when people start acting out of
line
but i think i think you can find god the
idea of god is is love
and i i think i have found that without
religion and that's why i can't fully
commit to a religion and i i really want
to
more than i it feels like it feels kind
of forced
for me like i i can't
i i want to follow these scriptures and
everything but
um romney was making the comparison to
how i think judaism christianity and
islam are all very similar i think that
a lot of religions are just different
versions of the same ideas different
days to go to church the mosque the
temple of the church it's it's you know
different hat what you what a woman can
wear what like a yamaka or it's all just
different variations of the same thing
be a good person that's what it boils
down to the ten commandments be a good
person in christianity so
yes it'd be nice to have rules to follow
but i've always attained the idea that i
can have those
goods i can have those good ideas
without religion and that's why when i
uh disrespected islam by by mocking the
prayer i wasn't afraid of the reaction
at the time because i knew that i was
coming from a good place and i thought
that islamic people or muslim people i
don't want to make the mistake i thought
that they would see the good intentions
i was trying to call out haram i was
trying to call out the actions that i
see around me so i thought that
actual religious people would have seen
would have been able to see that my
intentions were good i wasn't trying to
mock the religion i was trying to mock
the people who are acting out of line
that's why i was not afraid to do those
jokes
i understand how when it's clipped out
of context and you know i'm i'm up now
people the stream is growing and
everything there's a lot there's an
active amount of people who want to take
me down and my ideas and what i'm saying
can be misconstrued
but
i fee i really have this idea that i
am a good person and that i don't need
religion but i think eventually it will
happen and i've been an atheist for well
not an atheist but i've left religion
when i was very young when i was like 10
i went to catechism i went to church i
had to get my confirmation i was
baptized and everything i was told to
believe in god and i was sitting in
church and i'm like i don't
it's not it's just not hidden like the
priest is there it's telling us
a speech every day i think they call it
a sermon i want to um say it incorrectly
but it's like what does this priest even
know
this priest has never the girl
he's only been in the church all the
time like how much can i really relate
to this guy i want to get some
i want to be outside i want to start
business this guy doesn't know [ __ ] he's
this guy's name is phillip or his name
is like mark and he's just he wears like
a clothe like a wizard costume every day
and he sits and he talks but what the
[ __ ] does he know